so stories have been circulating the
last few days that president joe biden
was going to make armenian genocide
official this is a story from
yesterday from cnn president biden told
turkish president erdogan he's planning
to recognize
armenian genocide meaning going from
massacre to genocide and
just a few minutes ago it was
reported by associated press that
president biden
has officially recognized armenian
genocide
and this is how he wrote it in a
statement
and this is happening on april 24
2021. it's 106 years since
the genocide took place in 1950 by the
ottoman
empire and here's what his statement
reads and i'm going to go through a
couple of things with you this is a very
very big deal for the armenian community
very big to the millions of people that
march every year
to the the millions of stories that
armenians have heard from their
parents their grandparents their
great-grandparents if you had one that
was around mine was
we had a great grandma we called her
tompo babo and my grandma's name was
kanarik
and my grandpa's name was artus and my
mother's last name is borosian and we
would hear these
stories about why my mother and her
family left armenia and baku and ended
up
in back in the days bandar palavi but
this is the statement from joe biden i
want to read it to you
each year on this day we remember the
lives of all those who died in ottoman
empire armenian genocide
ottoman era armenian genocide and
recommit ourselves to preventing such an
atrocity from ever giving
ever again occurring beginning on april
24 1950 with the rest of
arrest of armenian intellectuals and
community leaders in constantinopole by
ottoman authorities
one and a half million armenians were
deported massacred and or
marched to their deaths in a campaign of
extermination we honor the victims of
the meds
jaegern so that jager and so the horrors
of what happened are never lost to
history and remember so that we remain
ever vigilant
against the corrosive influence of hate
in all its forms of those who survived
most were forced to find new homes new
lives around the world including the
united states with strength
and resilience the armenian people
survived and rebuilt their community
over the decade armenian immigrants have
enriched
the united states in countless ways but
they have never forgotten the tragic
history that brought so many
of their ancestors to our shoes we honor
their
story we see that pain we affirm the
history we do this
not to cast blame but to ensure that
what happened is never repeated today as
we mourn
what was lost let us also turn our eyes
to the future
toward the world that we wish to build
up for our children a world
unstained by the daily uh evils of
bigotry and intolerance where human
rights are respected and where all
people are able to pursue their lives
and dignity and security let us renew
our shared
resolve to prevent future atrocities
from occurring anywhere in the world and
let us pursue
healing and reconciliation for all the
people around the world the armenian
people honor
all those the american people honor all
those armenians who perished in the
genocide that began
106 years ago today i will tell you
i wouldn't be surprised and surprised if
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world are in tears right now crying
right and you have to understand this is
very difficult for the armenian
community because
60 countries nearly i believe the number
60 if not higher
have accepted this event u.s hasn't
years ago
reagan wrote about it in a statement it
was a speech that he gave
a proclamation i think it was a
proclamation that he gave
on april 22 1981 uh where he said a uh
the congress of united states
established united states holocaust
memorial so he's given a message about
this and then in the sentence there
he says like the genocide of the
armenians before it
and the genocide of cambodians which
followed it and like too many
other such persecutions of too many
other people the lessons of holocaust
must never be forgotten so it was a
message of holocaust
but he put armenian and genocide in
there
so what's written about biden said it
again today
one republican president one democratic
president fyi
a lot of other presidents both on the
left and the right obama you know many
of these
presidents promised that they were going
to make this
official i want you to know that i
applaud uh
joe biden for coming out here and
addressing this and doing this uh
you know also kudos to a lot of the
armenian folks around the world that
kept
talking about this marching about it you
know speaking to non-armenians who are
not aware of this
educating others whether it's marching
on twitter whether it's making videos
where they're discussing this
it's it's it's a very very special
monumental day i've been getting
messages from people all over the world
and you know
what's what's interesting about this how
do i take this because
i sat there and i was i was telling the
story the other day to a guy was talking
to
i said my memory of my grandma cannot
eat was my mother's mom
who was in bandar park la vie which is
north of tehran they had this place
which we would go to they had their dog
and you know would run around we had a
great time with them and there was this
room she would go to was always dark and
she would sit there and she would watch
russian television programming and she
would watch ballet or she would watch
gymnastics because russians it was just
a beautiful thing she would watch
and i grew up with these stories right
so to me
it's personal for the stories that i
heard now
to the average person who's watching
this saying well how does this affect me
look
everybody your heritage mind we all have
a certain story that we go to
and and for me one of the best videos i
ever watched was
in 2015 a video came out i think was nbc
maybe it was europe or uk or something
like that
and they went and interviewed surviving
those who survived the armenian genocide
it was a group of
31 that apparently was surviving it may
be a smaller number today but at that
time i think was 31. one of them was
born
who was 10 years old because the lady
was 110 years old so she was born in
1905 which means
she witnessed a lot of it exactly what
happened what they did there were four
sisters and she saw what happened what
they did right in front of him she's
shaking when she's talking
those are the ones who experience the
pain so if that's your grandma or your
great-grandma
that's emotional to you that's personal
to you and and those are the stories
that have
been passed down to us now
uh my phone is obviously blown up with
everything that's coming to me hey what
about this hey did you hear this hey did
you hear that did you hear that
what happens now why have we been slow
to do this
why has america been slow to do this why
didn't trump do this why
didn't trump just go and say hey let's
let's uh let me say the armenian
genocide because
you know uh you know let's let me say
the fact that these events did take
place but it didn't happen
even i think it was uh one of the
senators or congressmen led the way
you know we have two military military
bases
in turkey now that this event's taking
place
and biden has discussed with
erdogan behind closed doors hey i'm
about to do this i'm going to move it
from massacre to genocide and i'm going
to announce it on the 24th
i can only imagine how that call went
and on a call like that
you know the turkish empire they're a
very proud
proud nation very proud nation
so either us has to owe them a big favor
number one they're gonna have to
owe them a big favor for this to happen
number two
you're either gonna have these two
military bases that u.s has in turkey
right here these are two military bases
that we have in turkey
okay one of them is uh i believe this is
as updated i don't know the exact date
but we have a couple military bases two
or three military bases in turkey that
we don't know what's going to happen
with this u.s military bases are they
going to ask us to leave are they going
to say hey
you know are they going to get a lot of
are they sitting there right like
imagine if you're in a u.s military base
in turkey
your guard probably went up they're
probably even reported saying hey just
be careful here's what we did
you have to understand you may be mocked
when you go in the city i just want you
to know
this is what just took place and let
alone if you're an armenian soldier at a
turkish base
you're working for the u.s army you know
say i was armenian assyrian in the us
army so i can only imagine if somebody's
like that based over there but uh
it's going to be interesting so the
blowback what's the pushback going to be
here
one um this could
get us to owe turkey a favor or this
could get
turkey to get closer to russia and this
turkey to get closer to china and the
reason why turkey's a very important
country in the middle east is because
they have the strongest military
in the middle east so it's going to be
very interesting to see what happens
here
with that it takes a lot of guts to pull
it off
in order to do that the armenian
community is not as big as a turkish
community you have to understand it's
not like it's a
it's a political move well let me
announce this as armenian genocide
because
you know armenians have 80 million votes
or 40 million votes or 10 million votes
and
5 million votes and turkish don't have
any votes it's actually the other way
around the turks have way more votes in
the u.s than armenians do
i think the turkish population is bigger
in the u.s than it is
than the armenian vote and as well as
the turkish as a nation
is way more powerful this is turkey
right here this is armenia right here so
i applaud
the administration i don't agree with
everything folks on both sides but when
you do something that i agree with i
want to also recognize that as well
so kudos to uh biden and their
administration for
uh remembering you know recognizing
armenian genocide
as an event that did take place not
using it as a massacre not using it as a
tragic event but saying specifically
a genocide genocide hasn't happened too
often it's
it's you know these events that you read
about uh
often the the country that is going
through this
uh rarely wants that to be taking place
it took germany a long time to pay their
debt and the reparations of what they
did
to the jews in germany holocaust
i have a very strong feeling a good uh
feeling that
many of the armenian politicians are
going to go to
uh these are going to go to dc and
they're going to campaign
on getting some sort of reparations for
this because it's categorically a
genocide
and it's going to be very interesting to
see how turkey responds to that so the
next moves
uh will be very very anything could
happen at any moment if nothing happens
the next four weeks i will be surprised
i don't think erdogan is just going to
sit there and say hey it's okay don't
worry about it
it's okay guys let's just move on i
don't see him as a leader like that
i see him making some comments about
this and it'll be very interesting to
see everybody react moving forward more
importantly if you're armenian watching
us if you're syrian watching this this
is a event that took place with
armenians assyrians and the greeks
because it was the
christian community and the number has
it to be
one and a half million armenians uh 500
000 to 750
000 greeks and a quarter million
assyrians so i'm armenian and assyrian
it's a it's a it's an atrocity what
happened to those three communities
back in 1915. once again
um very happy that this is official
and i'm looking forward to seeing what
happens from here moving forward to all
the armenians out there that were
constantly
going out there injecting your beliefs
in a very peaceful protesting way around
the world when you were marching
i applaud you i have a lot of respect
for you
and i know this is a very big victory
for all of us